when you think about why bitcoin only i
think people hear that they're like oh
but there's 10 000 other coins that you
could participate in we've seen everyone
from some of the publicly traded uh
fintech firms that have come out and
showed that a lot of the trading a lot
of the revenue is coming from
non-bitcoin assets why focus only on
bitcoin focusing only on bitcoin allows
us to differentiate um and it allows us
to build the
new financial products
around bitcoin that haven't been built
before the reason that we're focused on
bitcoin isn't because we don't like
money
um it's because
there are a million apps where you can
buy
every cryptocurrency under the sun um we
deeply believe that only bitcoin is on a
trajectory to truly become this reserve
currency of the world the money of the
internet and we think that we've only
the industry has only scratched the
surface
and the types of financial products um
that are offered that are that are
bitcoin native help help you grow your
bitcoin wealth directly uh and that's
what we're doing with this new product
we launched this river mining product
which i'm happy to talk more about but
um we think that there's a whole world
of bitcoin specific financial products
left to build and that's what we want to
do and we think that there's going to be
a huge demand for that and by focusing
on a bunch of other cryptocurrencies
would distract from our ability to
execute on that vision so what's
fascinating to me is one avoiding
distractions almost it's more important
to know what you don't do than it is
what you do do right which i think is is
uh pretty compelling uh the second is
that you've talked in the past about a
lot of people going to certain platforms
uh and being confused or overwhelmed or
even having almost like what i call like
sticker shock right oh one bitcoin is 60
000 this other thing is less than that
so maybe i should just buy that thing
talk through a little bit as to how you
see uh maybe the the negative sides of
uh some of the platforms that offer a
bunch of stuff and then what is the
negative sides of only focusing on
bitcoin right there's trade-offs to this
stuff so like what do you think as the
the downsides to both of the strategies
yeah there are certainly trade-offs so
on on the in on the pros side b bitcoin
only allows us to have the most simple
experience possible people like our app
because they get exactly what they want
and what they need they want to buy
bitcoin and hold bitcoin that's what
they get they don't get other confusing
features widgets random coin launches
scammy looking things going on um they
feel very comfortable especially sending
uh
sending new novices new new bitcoiners
over to our platform because they know
that they're not going to get distracted
by uh
and get confused between the difference
between bitcoin and bitcoin cash or
bitcoin sv or bitcoin gold or um you
know ethereum and solana and chiba and
doge uh they know they're just going to
be on a safe path and they're going to
get exactly what they need
on the downside
um
people do want to speculate on these
long tail coins people do want to some a
lot of people do want to buy ethereum a
lot of people do want to buy solana
and you know
being
like any app uh you have to decide you
know
do you do try to do it all or do you
focus on what you can do better than
anybody else and um if you look at sort
of the best apps in the world the best
companies in the world they focus on
what they can do better than anyone else
and um that's how we think about it when
you start to look at the various
products you guys started with brokerage
in custody uh explain kind of the
progress of that business i don't think
people realize how quickly you guys uh
have grown
yeah so uh our brokerage and custody
business kind of really
blew up this year in a good way um you
know our our assets under custody and
volumes have been up year over year
dramatically
it's been a good healthy business for us
but in our mindset you know brokerage is
actually really just the first stepping
stone on a much longer journey
brokerage is really just getting us from
zero to you know i would say 0.5 getting
all the way to one for us is building
this suite of financial services that
are bitcoin native that nobody's ever
had before and so um well brokerage has
been successful and fun to build and i
think we've done a great job building
the best bitcoin brokerage out there
especially for the higher end of the
market
it's really just the start of our
journey
and then talk to me about this mining
product that you have in terms of uh
allowing people in a very seamless
frictionless way
to get exposure to mining and to start
mining
yeah so this new mining product we just
launched river mining
is
the is is the next big financial product
that we're offering after brokerage uh
the way we think about this product is
making bitcoin mining as easy as we've
made buying bitcoin
uh to date mining bitcoin has been
pretty confusing and pretty much um the
only people who mine bitcoin are
industrial bitcoin miners or hobbyists
who really deeply uh get into the weeds
they have to understand what pools are
even if somebody else is hosting their
miners for them there's a lot of
complexity and nuance and things they
really need to understand um and that
that nobody's and nobody's abstracted
that complexity away before
um
we're making bitcoin mining as he's just
clicking a button uh as easy as uh you
know
almost consumerizing spinning up an aws
like instance right you click a button
you'll get a miner and you don't have to
worry about anything else and the
bitcoin from that miner shows up in your
uh river account
uh the miners you actually own so not
only do you have the bitcoin income
stream from this miner but you own the
underlying asset as well